What we usually care about when we analyze programs
is what's called the worst-case execution time. And that's the
case where the input for a given size takes
the longest possible time to run. So for our lookup,
the worst case will be either the very last
entry in the table, or a keyword that doesn't exist
in the table at all. Let's look at the
code for lookup to understand more why the time scales
the way it does, and think about what the worst case
execution time and what the average case will be. So, to get
a better understanding of the results we've seen, let's look at the
codes that we wrote for the index. This is the code that
we finished in the last unit. And we have the code for
lookup. So, what lookup is doing, it's going through a loop. Each
of the entries in the index. And remember that index is a
list, so it's going through that list for each element, it's checking,
does it match the keyword. So this is our index structure,
right? It's a list of elements. If we had 10 million
of them, it's a very long list with lots of elements.
But each element is a list itself, where we have keyword
followed by the list of URLS where it appears. And what
lookup is doing is going through those entries. The number of
times we go through this loop depends on the size of
the index. The size of the index is the maximum number
of times through that loop. And it also depends on,
well, if we find the keyword early, then we're done.
The other code that you see here, that's relevant to
this, is the code for add_to_index. And the reason that's relevant
is, we want to know what the structure with index is
after we make our big index. And what add_to_index does is
also loop through all the entries to find if one
already exists, then it adds that URL. If one doesn't exists,
it adds the new entry at the end. So this means
that the first entry we add will always be at the
beginning. That's why the aaaa, with eight a's is first. And
the last one that we add will be at the end.
So now, we'll have a quiz to see if you understand
what it means to be the worst case input and how
the code for lookup works. The question is, which of these
inputs will have the worst case running time? So the choices are,
doing lookup, passing in the index and the first word that
was added to the index. The second choice is doing lookup,
passing in the index, and a word that is not in the index. And the third choice
is calling lookup, passing in the index, and is the second
input passing in the last word that was added to the index. So, for
the quiz, you should check all the
answers that have the worst case running time.